hate it when people welcome to the room
a report on Dave Rubin and we have a
smart and a heady show
Korea as opposed to the not smart not
Eddie shows that with a pump it out the
last year
jacko England Cara Santa Maria these are
two
smart science the checks
can I say that are you were comfortable
with that description I am signed and
chi-x
area were okay with it up in a paycheck
is is that
debatable RI I feel good about this we
got a budget topic that I think that
they're really gonna want to sink their
teeth into
so here we go a school in
Fort Lauderdale Florida is in a bunch of
hot water
after it teacher reportedly banned one
of her students from reading the Bible
during free reading time she actually
called
the parents a phone at home and left a
message and we've got money
first
and shot kept
I don't I'd
ok cash-strapped
tall
first first
art direction to first
fast call
Frank I
okay so this brings up a lot interesting
things obvious about freedom of religion
in this was free
reading time at the school which implies
that the kids can read anything that
they want to read
now I know you guys are a huge on
religion
so I thought this would be an
interesting topic for you guys to handle
what do you make of them
best teacher it was in a school-wide
thing apparently but this
teacher felt that this kid could not
read the Bible in class is that
okay no i i don't think that's okay I
mean
I'm normally very against having
religion in schools but that
having the school push religion on the
kids in this case the kid just with an
individual
who wanted to bring the book to school
read it and it's a personal choice and I
don't think that should be
handle the way that they did you know
Cara personal choice
well I mean yeah the first amendment and
protect my right to not read the Bible
the same way protect this child right to
read the Bible this is a blatant
violation of the Constitution
and there's a you know there's action
being taken now their lawyers that are
working with the
with that student's family and this
could potentially be pushed up through
the court system
though I'm not sure if this teacher is
aware of the fact that she's violating
the Constitution by telling this child
that he can't read this book in her
classroom and maybe
that'll be corrected as soon as she
kinda remove the Constitution yeah
like that can read the Bible is gonna
influence the other kids around them
you never know it's not being forced to
anybody even if it didn't want the other
kids around him it doesn't matter
because
the truth is that is a a choice that
our like the law of the land protect
though this wasn't something that was
like you that part of the curriculum
this is there something the teacher was
pushing on to the student but yes you
have every right to read whatever
religious text you want to read in a
public place in a private place whatever
it be one thing if he was reading this
book when you're supposed to be reading
Tom Sawyer and reading a big stink about
it but in free reading
class to tell us to do that yet to take
bilateral glasser
his career and out of the classroom his
store out of the classroom whatever is
yeah it's a violation of the First
Amendment yeah I don't like carrying
around a correr it or is mad
I think the bigger bull it's very likely
that the huge thing I did I used to
think that kinda India in israel like
that there are giant bibles 0 I'm ready
I can dollar can you have that i pod
people pushing her away and I will for
give up to kids bibles america fuck yeah
other yeah I got a million others liked
stupid Bible at are you writing mad
about this I thank you
um should we be a little afraid a
so what we're blaming this on the
teacher not the the school itself so
that that's when the but should we be a
little afraid of these people that
are pushing the anti-religion being even
if you're not for
religion in the public sphere that
they're pushing it to this extent like
that she called she said
you know this isn't gonna happen in my
class that there's a there's a danger
really in her methodology at how she's
trying to preach
liberalism absolutely i mean there's as
much of a danger there
weather is pushing religion on kids you
don't wanna make up their mind for them
it should be up to the child is worse
than before
yeah so every night another child can
really make those kinds of decisions I
mean that's another
that's another debate entirely but aside
from that I i think we need more contact
like sheep
reaching anti-religion or she so a
parade a First Amendment violations and
afraid of all the things that she's been
in the news lately that she thought that
this was the right course of action like
oh no I don't a Bible in my classroom
because I could get in trouble for that
maybe like that's the thing is that when
you become very extreme on one side or
the other
the issue I think and because it's such
a polarized issue it's such a political
kinda
hot-button issue I think that there's
confusion surrounding and this
again we don't we don't have contact it
could be that this woman was trying to
push
a specific agenda it could be that she
was afraid up the opposite agenda being
you know it seeming like it's being
pushed in her class arms up I think with
a little more context we would
understand it's a little better but
until then it kinda hard to tell yet
where you guys following terms a
love where'd where the debate should be
on this because there is so it seems to
me
you could teach in history class you
could teach about the historical
existence FG's is and what was going on
in that time
without giving a religious context to it
but should but you want to start doing
that then you open up a can of worms
where everyone wants to
bring all the the miracles and all that
in it so we're waiting for in terms of
what we can teach without
teaching near so obviously there's no
viable evident that you have actually at
all
maari
yeah all right he wrote a book about the
historical
yeah go yeah plays halo their their
their stories there's you no
corroborating
like tales and myths and and and maybe
nine minutes we don't know but there's
no
there's no actual evidence that there
was a historical figure in Jesus the way
that there's evidence of historical
figures
who you know wrote things or where we
have you know their bowling
someplace like that that doesn't exist
for for Jesus Christ so
so and I'm not saying I don't think
Jesus Christ existed I have no fucking
idea
but I don't think than one empirical
everyone here at 11 and there's
absolutely nothing wrong with talking
about the history of religion and
history philosophy in those types of
courses I don't know it
like jesus's existed should be talking a
history class
regular I don't think we should be
making I mean the sorry that is that the
distinction that should be taught the
purity in high school for example should
be taught in social studies
but it could be taught in in a velocity
yeah there's a lot to be there electives
you can choose to take religion you can
have Bible study classes
outside at the high school mean but you
can't just sit there and say that I know
Jesus was historical summit Egypt you
can teach the affects
that religion had a history man it's
important to carefully avoided yeah
that's going to be part of your history
class regardless if you're learning
about kinda American history or if
you're learning about world history like
you can't avoid a conversation about
religion
but I think religion as institution and
its sociological effect is a very
different conversation
then the lower and the dogma within a
religion being taught us
backed like that that's where I start to
the charge actually existing in and
having political
you know Mac an Asian thing like that
that's real the a walk on water stuff
emad yeah
well we're all agreed that part of my
husband and I know what I am going
nowhere
near science yeah right there you go I
with some that when a pretty well
let me but I thought this was kinda
fascinating a 25-year-old woman named
Emily let
with an abortion counselor from New
Jersey she filmed herself having an
abortion and this thing is blowing up
you might have seen it already
we're gonna shaded a little bit just
mention to me
on
show women very soon
have abortions during
now on
at
yeah that
fine
you
well as obviously she was trying to show
a positive abortions are in fact the
pro-abortion abortion counseling I
believe
a woman's right to choose and I have no
right to tell women what to do with her
own body
but after watching this I was really
kinda conflicted
this sorta helps the cause abortion or
not because by showing something
that clinically it actually paid a go to
a little weird to me really did
what you think I mean okay like it
personally I think my very first
response when I watch this was like I
don't care
but I don't think I'm the audience or
that for the a story I
a I've never had an abortion but like
you I'm
pro-choice I have friends who have had
abortions and I don't think that I am
eating
YouTube video to understand the process
but that's me I would
research it in different ways I think if
I were faced with that
difficult but we on aggression may or
not be going to the character in a mere
I'm yeah every democrat exactly I'm not
you know but
at New my fuckin response when I saw
this video with like
you know air like it not well done
that like I think that was my problem
shuster trying to force with the music
and Michael with a positive attitude
it's like
okay it it the personal experience yeah
it an experience that could have
positive
I'll often does have positive
ramifications in somebody's life down
the line but
with having an outpatient procedure is
like
you know something that needs violin
music behind it just you're right puts a
bad taste in your mouth a little bit and
I think more than anything
all this video is really going to do is
gonna polarize people
if you look at where it was posted the
article where I first read it from
with on a conservative site and the
victory all in the comments section
with like 0 I mean granted she must have
known that was gonna happen
I don't blame her I think that you know
she has the right to
to make this kind of statement and
honestly maybe if she did touch one or
two young women who were like
I want to do this but I'm afraid I think
that it's gonna hurt
I think it's gonna you know ruin my life
and they want to go maybe it's not that
bad I actually do have an option
yeah amino well and you're totally right
about strengthening the others I think
that once this thing got posted on
Drudge then it goes to cross the right
weighing blog a spear and everyone
starts granting get it do you generally
agree with that
I mean I generally do I think I feel bad
because your I didn't get posted on a
conservative website the comments for so
hateful towards her
they said that she got pregnant on
purpose so that she could do this and
get all this attention which is just
because we love having abortions around
I'm not a look now but
right there now it really parties and
really touchy subject in like I'll try
to avoid saying that I'm pro-abortion
and say that I'm pro-choice because no
one wants the pro-abortion like yeah
abortions are us on the right but how
many people I think that like
yet it it something that most women use
as a form of birth control because it
somehow
easier without you there to just not
think about it get laid what the fuck
ever other take care the baby it's like
woman wants to do that it can't be
comfortable
and I it is emotional for most be held
what a medical problem sometimes people
can't get pregnant after having an
abortion there's a lot of serious
consequences with that and it can be
psychologically detrimental
which is something that I think the one
the biggest reasons why didn't like this
video is because she's just so what
happy the whole time in
that's good because like you said it's
important showgirls already made the
choice
to have an abortion that it's not going
to hurt you know it's not gonna the
as horrible as they might think it could
be and it kinda give them some
reassurance but the same time
it's kinda like almost encouraging away
right so it sounds like you both agree
that her idea was good here but that the
way they produce this with the music and
you know her it like she was going so
far out of her way to make it seem like
it was okay
that also you know we don't see the
clinical things it will remind me awake
the death penalty
when we don't see these people being put
to death I'm against the death penalty
anywhere
but like if we don't see it we don't
know what's going on a bike seeing her
laying there
if felt much more humid it actually was
making me rethink my position a little
bit I'm still pro-choice I mean that
kinda what my first reaction was just
like the production values are so
terrible
I feel like if it had been produced a
little bit differently
like if if she had you know edited
things a little bit differently shown
it look like you selectively edited to
only show the part where he is the most
comfortable she never once said like
okay this part is a little Inc okay I'm
I'm pass it up after it
if it had felt a little more real to me
because I'm I do kind of like the idea
though that we were in that room with
her
experiencing it with her and she was
sharing that intimate moment
to so that people would understand like
if I can do it
and you're free to do it but you know
you need to do what you can do it to you
yeah but it with almost forced in this
weird kinda hard to come by all buy it
when he said yeah I'm really unrealistic
just no one's gonna be that excited that
happy
to go through this process i feel like
im sure showed both sides right and of
course
you know she I'm not saying she got
pregnant and not going i'm noticing she
got pregnant
to do this video but obviously her
allegiances are where they are because
working out there so she wanted to spend
it in a in a certain way
what do you guys make above the main
basically that
try to tell you what to do and because
it's pretty much all men or a huge
percentage Amanda
the Toros voting on abortion and Andy
Gray and allegedly writing a red
graduation all that and I'm always
fascinated by XI
literally cannot understand how someone
who does not have the body part
Kim can tell you what to do with your
body parts
now totally great there needs to be more
women in legislation so that kinda thing
doesn't happen
but I don't want to be too one-sided
because I feel like certain women who
are in relationships
have abortions without telling your
significant other and I can be
kinda gray area I think or you might
need to actually talk to the Father
I are you think they should have some
sort of like force you know I don't
think generation I don't think so but I
just feel like to say that you know men
have no say and they shouldn't even be
able to give me their opinion on it I
think that's going too far
yeah I mean of course I think men should
be able to give you their opinion
yeah or talk to the people that are
voting yeah I mean I'm back her sleep
feel very strongly that until the baby
is born
like it it a women's health issue and a
women's health issue
alone and Dylan this you know this
organism is viable on its own what we're
all
really talking about is a medical
condition pregnancy is a medical
condition for a woman
yeah and it's a choice that she is
deciding to make the same way that you
can make a choice
about the best treatment option for her
cancer
the same way that she can make a choice
about a you know whether or not you want
to elect to have certain surgeries and
yes
I think that having outside perspectives
is helpful
I hope that if you're you're only lucky
enough to be in a situation where there
is a man in your life
yeah we the willing to give you his
opinion about the situation because
many times in a woman is faced with the
decision having an abortion she
on her fuckin own and that even more
difficult but
it's her choice fundamentally it is her
choice and nobody has the right whether
we're talking about legislators
or we're talking about people with
personal relationships to tell a woman
what she can and can't do
with her own pregnancy because until
that baby is born
it is a women's health a medical issue
so you're saying
until that baby is born do you guys have
a cut-off is there a cut-off point is
that the other debate you know is it the
two trimesters is it I didn't seem to me
that look if you were to say eight
months while that
baby probably could live I think it's
silly to draw a line to be honest
it but I think it's silly to draw a line
like obviously when the baby is born
then there are certain legal issues that
you can argue with right but before that
I feel like if an individual's
you know perspective on the situation
and that's why I'm pro-choice because my
opinion on that might not be the same if
somebody else's opinion that I recognize
that
you know I personally don't think I
could go through having an abortion but
that has nothing to do with my you know
willingness to vote on whether
not somebody else can you know I'm not
gonna be pushy I mean obviously there
are legal
issues that and you know in a perfect
world we don't often think about so sure
maybe there's a woman whose ate half
months pregnant she's abusing drugs and
alcohol the courts wanna be able to say
right you're abusing a life inside view
and we should be able to force you to
maybe
stop doing that we should be able to
force you to you have the child instead
Obama and that's where things start to
get really
touchy and really a you know to go look
at that but
I it if the complicated topic I think
but the problem
most of the time when it comes to this
kind of legislation
is not motivated by those specific
situations I think that legislation is
generally motivated by
religious bias and
a int there are people who go to the
extreme that they'll say that like the
actual
feed the actual for me is you know
ordained by God and that that shouldn't
even be spilled so I I'm pretty sure my
yeah I bet the whole other topic
up by two final thought on it is this
you know I was thinking
this putting this type of thing on
YouTube really such a 2014
thing is there something very freeing
happening in the digital
year that we can put this about their
that whether it's whether it's good or
bad weather we watch this and whether
it's strengthening the other side or not
or whether it's really affecting a
change anyone's mind
that can be more pro-choice this is all
good though just the information right
yeah I think that overall it a positive
thing just because it does give that
comfort to girls who've decided to have
an abortion but
I do see how it can really be a
lightning rod for the opposite side
yeah and that's what frustrates me the
most because religious people are the
ones who are saying
don't masturbate don't use condoms don't
take birth control and then they wanna
legislate against abortions it's like
well maybe if you were a little bit more
open minded about
prevention it's very cool that we're
living in a world right now
where free speech is and
is kinda helped by multimedia
and by the fact that we can use
something as simple as
the the camera on our phone to produce a
video in to tell a message in a much
more compelling way
then just standing outside and hoping
that people gather around us to hear
what we have to say
and we at least have that free money
internet for a little while longer
although
net neutrality was struck down with
we've also talked about a thousand times
so you know good luck to us all okay let
you know what let's talk about porn cuz
I'm sure that not going anywhere on the
internet
Arizona's Republican Governor Jan Brewer
you know jan Brewer
she signed a law this week cracking down
on revenge porn
classifying it as a sex offender course
revenge porn is when
you post photos or videos usually have
an accent yours without their consent
there's a budget state that have this
would get a little info on law
Arizona's strict new law makes revenge
pointer Belletti
establishing an initial 18 months in
prison or two and a half years in prison
if the person in the image
can easily be identified it will apply
to any photographs videotape
film or digital recording a person and
it makes it a crime to disclose display
distribute publish
advertise or offer these photos or
videos
I the themes all good to me I usually
don't agree with jan Brewer
but they seemed pretty good is there
anything wrong with this kinda law and
did we really just need this
because a that was my question like why
do we have to say they are not allowed
to post
revealing photos up your act on the
Internet like better be albeit should be
I
do that are no people sometimes have a
bad major I'm
yeah I think gallery yeah I mean it's
ridiculous that the even had to be fed
like don't
be an asshole don't break don't murder
people don't
post pictures people on the internet for
everyone to see and invade their privacy
like that
common sense whether the original
eleventh commandment thou shalt not pose
for pictures having
everybody that level up a lot a yeah
all good here ordered openly I mean
obviously this
needs to be legislated because a people
will argue that this is a violation of
free speech and that they should have
the right to
be able to say this and if there's
something in their possession especially
you know it get complicated when
somebody takes felt the and the
interesting thing is that some of these
revenge porn laws actually
don't apply to you self recorded the in
in Arizona they do but in rather stay to
love them don't apply to like self
recorded images which I think
is a new one that shouldn't be written
into the law but that's where I think
the legality gets confusing because I
took a picture myself naked and gave it
to you and that this is now your
property
he does although then yeah it's our
relationship yeah that's good
don't gotta okay well aa work already a
at though if I did that you should
you know you might be able to argue that
it now your property and you can do
whatever you want with it
on now i'm for it yeah unfortunately
there's no waiver signed
there are no relief there if they were
waiver signed this
revenge porn I would not apply right if
that actually
not a terrible idea like have an app
where you're going to send all your new
did you have to actually Alex Tanguay
saying I the reduction of all the time
if i film you on the street during an
interview in you don't want your face on
camera
you can choose not to sign the release
and then after blur your face that out
yeah
the fact that either you know private
experiences
that people will ultimately I think I
think that kind of the interesting thing
about this law
it's sort of like the separation between
a typical violent crime and a hate crime
because it motivated by something that's
really specific and really
dark and kinda violent and vengeful
and because I've that direct motivation
a
I think the penalty should be stronger
because the actual act
is is the I honestly like what is your
protection that act like what can you
argue in a courtroom right that the
oh yeah I did write in good faith and in
town as a pike
Senate that picture to all my friends
good yeah I just wanted to promote
the new deserve this other guy with gray
up his party from here that we got all
this technology so fast
you know any like the Internet is all
really for for our purposes it's like 20
years old you know it's not that long
ago that it was all dial
and we got all of this stuff webcams and
phone cameras in snapchat we got it also
passed
that everybody started doing all this
crazy stuff and now it's like we'd need
these laws to control us because
otherwise
it's just sell it right yeah people are
people not the brightest soldiers do
whatever they can with what they have i
mean
it's not the technology's fault though I
mean we have a bunch of things our
disposal of your choice to
to be a jerk with it so now at the
technology's fault but definitely people
are going
a little bit crazy and have to make laws
like this where short-sighted as a
society that's part of the problem is
that people make decisions that seem
good in the moment
and they don't think about the
ramifications down the line and it's
also
difficult because there's no legislation
in place protecting
miners heard fresh and so now we are you
in the country all the time about the
legal drinking age the legal driving it
look at what point are you responsible
enough to operate heavy machinery or
you know at take a substance that
psychotropic
and so yeah at what point are you
responsible enough to
have at camera and the ability to upload
any picture that you take onto the
internet it's difficult when you're
young person
it even harder to think about the
downstream ramifications and their
biological reason for that
that part of your brain isn't well
developed though and we're also not
socialized to have that kinda
responsibility at that age that that's
where
things get difficult that's why I think
it is so important to have legislation
like this
yeah I am totally on board we were all
in agreement there are right there you
go
let that lets move on OK I'm very
excited to talk about this because we do
a lot of stuff by the show that all the
crazy shit
that in our food all the WAC Dow
Chemical better in yoga mat that you're
reading a
Inc so I am and everything else that
every time we do want the story the
comment section below crazy
and they yell at me and they say I'm at
the Sayed because I'm even bringing this
up and it in there and it's not gonna
kill you that seems to be a general
theme
I think it's weird that we Bieber anal
gland use and
I know what labor I think that we're
tied it may not kill me I just think it
odd that someone
with squeezing the Bieber is a decent
but stays good
grow up the what I want to be that guy
but I understand a little more about
times than I do and break somebody
stepped down because you might have
heard this week that coca-cola has
announced
that it's not going to use brominated
vegetable oil oil
or Bebo in soft drinks such as bad
press/graham Powerade anymore
I and this comes after a lot of people
were talking online
about how BBDO is related to compounds
that are found in fire retardant so
let's look at a little more info on Bebo
it contain the chemical bromide which is
also founded by retarded
said small quantities a BB or legally
allowed in some drinks to ensure
even labor distribution according to the
Center for Science in the Public
Interest
bebo is a poorly tested and possibly
dangerous
food additive and there's no reason to
use it in Gatorade or other drinks
a so before we get to the next thing I
want to stop there for a second because
as I said when we do this every one
yells at me they say well if you don't
eat a ton a bit you'll be okay we put
chemicals in our body all the time and
everything
as chemicals in the Inc has is getting
chemicals in Yucaipa
and you made a chemical and you're
making ever go today all of that right
yeah all of that so can you guys give me
just sorta
a basic break something to give me
something to pick this conversation of
so I'll start by saying that I think
that the people in the comment section
and there's a lot of validity to what
they're saying because they're is as a
especially in liberal media their is
kinda
up quick tech to immediately be afraid
have anything that corporation produces
at and immediately be afraid of words
like
molecule or can I call an hour and you
know and
all the Senate on dangers we have this
debate all the time with genetically
modified organisms
we have this debate with you no
preservatives food additives whatever
yeah so their is I'll
their is a reason to kind of stop sit
back and think about this
rationally okay I'm on board so they
will start their now I personally
don't know much about Bevo as a food
additive
but when organizations that are there to
protect the public interest
are do their research and do their due
diligence is a okay
we don't know much about this there are
many nations that have banned it
I no that's not reason enough for us to
you but the clincher for me
there's no reason for it to be there
because you can have the same effect if
you use something that's been proven to
be
say right why aren't we using the thing
that's been proven to be
day I me think about having to do with
money yet you think possibly
it could be a financial decision
probably and that's the cool thing
I think about living in the Internet age
is that if enough people get wind
have an issue and write a petition and
get loud about it and say I'm gonna buy
your product anymore because I'm
I'm afraid if there's one thing that
you're using it that I don't think
has been clearly tested and I'm not sure
about the health benefits of it
want to stop by coca-cola product Google
have to respond
they see a drop in profit and then make
their product better even if
night killing us they can make it more
natural and that you may not have a good
basic is it fair to say
that things that are natural are
basically good number I like that the
economic argument yet everything is
natural
yeah every girl record any artificial
stuff yeah
it occurs in nature that I O I hate to
be that Nikki but I know that everybody
can I help lead
no but i mean it's true and I think it's
a good to fine things you think are
unhealthy point them out
and replace them with something that's
better especially that think that's
better is available at a while he said
we're not
already using that to begin with but
yeah
money but there's a lot of people out
there who
like to think about the things and they
freak out about it because they want to
be like I'm health-conscious
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna take this
initiative and do better with this issue
but there are no ring everything else
like they're ignoring the ammonia that
people used to disinfect meet their
ignoring
all the hard things like him I mean yeah
I mean there's just so many things out
there that are
exponentially worse but nobody cares
about to hop onto this one issue
and feel better about themselves as a
whole because they're taking care one
tiny little detail okay to just to talk
about the things I projected to get
everybody nights and we got a couple
videos on it
so basically they're taking the worst
the worst meet stop literally it's
falling on the floor
then they pile it all together they wash
it with ammonia you were not in the wash
it with ammonia to kill
all the E-coli horrible sup it on there
and then we'd any is
edible it is humid before they do that
process it's not even fit for human
consumption
the meat and that and then it is but
when we don't do not even then people
say well they've done what they're
supposed to do so it's okay but you
wouldn't you would not agree with that
now I wouldn't accept that was washed
with bleach either I mean
it doesn't matter what they've done to
it two different but it's still really
unhealthy not to mention all the
hormones and stuff that you find in me
rates just I mean really bad for you I
take a really nuanced approach you like
specifically for talking about pink
slime
that because let's say that I am living
in the inner city and I don't have the
monetary means to eat at Whole Foods
yeah
and I don't have them the means to grow
my own I mean
ho courtly II like the idea of getting
back to a slow food movement
I like the idea of getting back to you
the ones you can get to the source of
your food
if there's you are steps that it takes
before that makes it your mouth
it more likely I think generally
speaking I'm not gonna say as a rule
but generally speaking it more likely
that that food will be
healthier the left process to get the
more process to get the the more we get
into the conversation
about food that weirdly
kinda paradoxically make this obese but
also
make this malnourished and that's a huge
problem in in this country specifically
but of that
going into other Western nations so when
it but when you say
if something more natural it's probably
better for you that bullshit because
like anne shit
this I yeah like and I go out to eat
throughout shit like that natural enough
genital particularly day out here yeah
there are certain things that
a we talk about that first-ever horribly
dangerous the you know there's
toxic things all over the place and
major and kemp Kenneth
have been able to extract things and to
you a
to add things together in such a way
that they take natural ingredients and
make powerful drugs out of them
and make powerful substances and make
food use food science to make things
that taste better and that or whatever
and so I think the issue is as you
always like to say this is an important
point
follow the money like what is the goal
here is the goal feeding people and and
feeding them nutritious food or is the
goal
you know a a multinational corporations
profit motive coca-cola and I'm the
first to admit I love Coco endangered
everyday like my biggest life it's
horrible for you that brought you a big
ass Coca Cola drink
I think we'll always a big idea all
night like I don't drink alcohol I don't
smoke I don't do drugs at my by
like that is my life but it's not good
for you
like in no sense of the term is drinking
a coke something that you need for good
basic nutrition high fructose corn syrup
and I could be in my arms feel
completely screwy causes all sorts a
health problems like liver problems and
diabetes like your body shouldn't take
in
much sugar yeah so what we're talking
about here
is are these corporations making
decisions in the best interest of your
help
probably not the probably making
decisions in the best interest up their
profits as you mentioned so we need
legislation
we need regulation that protect the
consumer
but we also shouldn't be so
trigger-happy that every time we hear
the word chemical
make the shake in our boat because
everything it may never have occurred
Open Beta Tau so speaking at the
corporation for the
the big thing that kick this off a
couple months ago was the subway thing
that we've alluded to
and the chemical that is in the bread or
was in the bag that nothing as called
adan let's get some more info about ADA
its primary use is in plastic and rubber
products like yoga mat and flip flops
where it used to make them softer and
more stretches up you wonder
why the bread at Subway so plot be in
stretchy you think maybe if I do that
many bread products often contain a DA
which is used to make job more elastic
an ATA is known to increase the risk
asthma allergies and skin problems
and we've got a with a buncha food that
actually contain edta
McDonalds by and check play fair which
is Burger King bun
Dunkin Donuts Wendy's bread armistead
like Roger I mean everything
pretty much everything I don't see it
out on there which is nice a metal how
should we fear
this because this this one seems a
little more close to home to me cuz
you can sorter like really tangibly see
why the bread
you mean you get great if you get
regular you go to a bakery and get a
bread
it's not as floppy and stretchy so there
is some connection between the robbery
feeling
a yoga mat and this bread so can I at
least make that well let can you guys
grab raid in our minds like
just because it has a one-component
doesn't mean we're eating yoga mat like
I think that that is the thing we
immediately jumped yeah I'd like
okay this chemical found in these two
products so therefore these two products
are the same thing
yeah and don't know we are not eating
yoga mat let's get that clear we okay I
really hate that jump a little bit more
like this one
we we don't know if those quantities
there were harmful I don't think there's
enough research but again if you can
make it without the damn thing
yeah and it and there's even a chance at
it
more healthy for the consumer then there
you go that's a great idea
I mean why not and I do like that the
power up the consumers
collective boy made a change for Subway
because that way tried to tout
themselves as a more healthy alternative
and they don't want to have things in
their food that are going to make health
conscious consumers
turn away but if you're really that
concerned about it
the first option would be don't just
going oh yeah
at the end of the day by about as I mean
is that really the end they let you get
at least get that out that's what I've
been thinking this whole time like I
don't want to say you shouldn't fix the
problem that exists because
if you can you something healthier than
use it but at the same time
you're freaking out over one chemical
whenever you're eating
a mcdonald's hamburger you think about
what you're eating at home wrote that
isn't all the crap it in there and
you're freaking out about
ADA later it just seemed a little bit
and also I know the people will make the
economic argument that you talked before
the say they're not they don't have
access to this other food and things of
that nature
but I do think that you know you could
buy canned tuna for a dollar fifty
and yes to pride I've mercury poison is
my my my yeah
but there are some cheaper ways to eat
things I know it's not as quick as
McDonald's but there are ways
so it's not totally tied up with you
stacked against you
my advice is never throw up your hands
and just give up bright
yes this deck is stacked against you and
unfortunately you're going to the people
in certain economic situation
having left options and it's going to be
harder to make healthy decisions and so
yes
that fucking thought unfair and I think
we should be pushing
to have more healthy grocery options in
lower-income neighborhoods
I'm not saying that it the auction or
the best option is just fucking
eat McDonalds and cry about it like
obviously fast food is not healthy
like point-blank it's just not healthy
to eat fast food and as you said
wiry nit-picking about this one thing
when there's a million other reasons
that fast food is not healthy
yes of for healthier options but let's
all keep in mind
as we're sitting here in our comfy chair
in West Hollywood
to that some people don't have the
options that we have so we should at
least maintain perspective about it
technically we're in Culver City we are
right for you nations were calling on
people wouldn't know who had it right
for you
something that they had a referendum
aren't like that we had a good segue
here from with you should need
this is an interesting as study the game
experience marketing services
conducted a rolling survey to determine
whether there any patterns between
politics
and food eye-rolling surveys where you
got gather information over a long
period of time
and there are some interesting findings
which we've got a budget
the first what is conservative versus
liberal food chain so this is where
conservatives
by tonight conservatives
or love all charlie is Cracker Barrel
that one doesn't surprise me
they like home town buffet what is an
excellent
pop over after I dot Papa Murphy's
LongHorn Steakhouse okay so the same
these are meaty kinda things hearty
party is where the Liberals eating
California Pizza Kitchen that socialist
yeah
Macaroni Grill Ruth Chris Steak House
sounds kinda pricey on the border that
makes and
PF Changs everybody likes a lil no
change Asian food
next up conservative versus liberal fast
food chain
so the Conservatives they're digging
kristall I actually don't know what that
is
burger I don't know across the river and
claim a little burgers
yeah it kinda like White Castle okay
candidate that I think tanks and that is
why I look at it like a thought-out
there about what a burger that mostly
down south side
ataxia whatever shellac skis Delhi
which also I don't know that one where
am I i hella I have no the Sharma
chick-fil-a that one doesn't surprise me
and they like Steak N Shake which is big
in the midwest
where the Liberals in their fast food
Arbonne par a dirty
rebel girl taking an airport yeah
water bread water bread trip ole and you
know because portable is supposed to be
a
you know relatively healthy way as far
as that goes ago but which is basically
in Tripoli knock up
blimpie I thought that was interesting
they like it more than subway or
what's the Quiznos and a Starbucks week
or so that the Liberals are we hanging
out at Starbucks
I want more on supermarket chain change
this is where the Conservatives are gone
they're going to Randalls wife market
Piggly Wiggly
broke Shires and boomtown I
interestingly that so liberal broke
Shires brookie
my Berkshire russia rather me go back
yeah
going I want to dissect so I these first
the
what piggly wiggly I know about how they
have been to any these first four
poo towns big on the east coast yeah I
don't either st. resolve the matter how
are these rather than midwestern
other only ever done Piggly Wiggly you
know who they are where the Liberals guy
doing their food wrapping
I where a not being liberal
all food okay check with the a trader
Joe that's where I do much to my
shopping
Fred Meyer Acme and state way so there
are some
interesting I i think im going some
interesting stuff that is
do you think you can get more
information about what people believe
politically by this kind of stuff
them pot by polling them on actual
politics I think there might be
something to that liberals are if they
are much healthier
is that going back to the rate is a good
now liberal sorta why
help yourself yeah more vegetarian yeah
they're
do I mean I think that if you were some
sort of advertising your consumer
marketing company and you wanted to be
meeky about the way that you reach your
consumer
yes you could go this route they don't
think you're going to glean more
information
about somebody's political views than
asking them point blank what are your
political views I don't think that
there's some all teary you're like a
weird now everybody shops a hole for me
that way
everybody architecture it I think that
this is a
bullshit study point-blank this is the
bullshit study I remember once doing
a maybe with the Young Turks maybe it
was the point i remember i at a roller
being on the show with us
and talking about maybe was even the
common room and talking about a similar
study that was like
I can tell your political persuasion
based on the alcohol that you drink
and right know what you can tell it
where I live in the country
and the truth is there's a high
correlation between
this type of food consumption and
regional different that
yeah and there's also a high correlation
between those regional differences
and political affiliation and now those
things are being completed
carry this is a hundred percent wire
britt let us know because I'm not always
told on the studies but I think the very
interesting that they get out there
to look at the Buncombe a little bit I'm
not have there's also a high correlation
between people that wear Wranglers and
people that wear
I don't know J Brand Jeans and their
political persuasion it because where
you live
at J Brand that can be California if
California New York it's gonna be a
higher scale client shop that
you know North commerce active Avenue
and Wrangler Jeans like I'm from Texas
I know this this is going to be
something that people in the south are
going to be more likely to wear two
morow a fashion statement that you see
in this out
and so it's going to be more likely that
those people are conservative and
they're probably gonna drinks a whiskey
instead of wine do you think that that
spot
yeah or with the incentive vodka for
example so I think they're really just
regional differences in people because
that where I
under the movies somebody's restaurant
so take advantage of those racial
differences in our their purpose because
I know and I felt their Cracker Barrel
everywhere everywhere and I have friends
who refused to go to them because when
you walk in it's like there's do this
music playing
they've had to say John 3:16 all these
Bible though and they just feel
uncomfortable so they won't go into
brown gravy yeah
they make character really hard really
do here with this conversation that we
have a lot of times about
voting with their dollar which i think
that that you know the big chick-fil-a
today
WEA I mean maybe I'm just a sucker and I
grew up in Texas and I really like
chick-fil-a
I apologize I am NOT homophobic you know
the rail
but I like homophobic chicken K really
good and yeah
here's here's part iv: be issue I think
is that it's the deck is stacked against
a lot of consumers in this country and
if we chase the money
ultimately we're gonna get something we
don't like ultimately organic and
everything that we are polarized about
and that were politically against
and idle I get it if you're somebody who
can take the time to do your due
diligence and do I love your research
and pick up where you wanna shop
based on your political a affiliations
that's great and more power to you but I
don't like it when people get high and
mighty about telling other people that
they should do that to you because like
sign up fucking time in the day day
to research every single thing I spend
my money on
yeah it gets confusing I mean you know
are left to right
late daughter and a Bonner going to
prison right now for tax evasion and
Italy and like if you're against that
you know it's it goes from the top 20
to the bottom it goes from high to low
from magistrate a dark corner
all the time alone everything okay never
going after shock anywhere guarded gas
at BP
exactly and somebody's making it likely
that any better to get gas at exotic
know and companies making a decision
if you're shopping atm a multinational
conglomerate probably
that they're making money on the backs
of other people in this is a big
difficulty in capital with the fight
yes you can I generally up to eat at in
and out
over these other choices because I ate
healthier try and be I do appreciate
their corporate values a little bit more
and I'd much rather go to a mom-and-pop
then go to a big change
but there are times when I'm stock I
still have to put gas in my car right
now call it. we live it we all make
different choices an interesting
the BP thing you know the oil spill
obviously whichever which they were
completely at fault for
most people were boycotting their gas
stations which are franchised so you
weren't even hurting
the corporation the conglomerate you
were hurting the individual franchisees
which had nothing to do with any the
safety thing at chick-fil-a
it's on a totally franchise and so you
see like the chick-fil-a here in West
Hollywood
is not a homophobic chick-fil-a at all
people are boycotting they're like
where on the West Hollywood likely it
worked here later healthcare
and that's a problem you know is that we
don't know all the ins and outs a lot of
these deals are done kinda in the dark
in the shadow in that
the record available to the consumer and
taking political action
via your food choices i think is a good
idea
but I also don't think it's always a
reasonable
idea alright people there you go we
don't know everything about what
in our food and who selling author we're
doing the best we can okay
I wanted to quit if it isn't interesting
either
saudi Arabia's King Abdullah of Saudi
Arabia one of our biggest allies in the
Gulf
a which doesn't let women vote or drive
but at a different topic altogether
has introduced a series of new laws
which defines atheist
as terrorist at missus according to a
report from Human Rights Watch
and the the boys basically have come
into play
because the the growing number of Saudis
that are traveling to into Syria
to fight in the Civil War there and then
they're returning to Syria
with newfound part-time freedom and they
now have all these new
military skill and the monarchy is
basically afraid that all these new
ideas
is gonna cause what's happening in Syria
to happen in saudi arabia
let's look at Royal Decree 44
criminalizes participating in
hostilities outside the kingdom with
prison sentences
between three and twenty years article
one at the new provisions define
terrorism as calling for
EPS thought in any form or calling into
question the fundamentals are the
Islamic religion on which
this country is bait I thought as a Star
Wars guy I thought it was funny that I
broiled the Cree 44 which sounds so much
like
order 66 which is where they killed all
the jet I but I'd
have to tell you do that island okay
we've got to
to a PST right I mean I know you well
enough and I know your way
well mister I am
what the actor-director I don't believe
that there's somebody up there judging
me but I believe in the force basically
but I don't think I believe him either
I believe there's something happening
here that I can't really explain but I W
yeah odiaun even got I don't think I
cared how much I jerk off
alright alright alright I think he's mad
like a a
yeah God where you work all that I
created this little universe and I was
creating some others 10
not watching leave it at that yet yeah
that the DS I think you'd be like
in trouble with right now D OMG rather
not be
programming to make it okay okay I am
so art to add APS is there a bit was
bonkers thing you've ever I love that I
can be a terrorist without doing
anything
but I know I am it early ATF
in the left the increased like it it
doing less than being religious
it didn't laugh a bully so literally
without doing anything making any
decisions having any
belief system or insights into anything
where terror but can it can you
understand why a monarchy the
that has so much control of their people
and as I said doesn't let women vote
or drive yet can you understand why that
in a weird way is more of a threat I can
sorta see why they'd
see that concept as more of a threat
than actually
terrorism United Way of course that is
the problem with
living under a theocracy is that you're
going to have
legislation in place that morally
directed that
fundamentally based on the your specific
religious values and it going to you by
its very nature
target individuals that don't fit into
that box
and you know look at what's happening
right now in Brunei with assault and
overnight
past Sharia law in this country
minutes fucking insane like they are I'd
much rather go
number of someone's hand now for all
feeling if I go to Brunei it like I will
be put to death in five minutes like I
will figure out how to break some sort
of law that will
you know they kill your execute exactly
and so I I'd rather go to Saudi Arabia
but these are shades of shit
is what we're talking about right now
and yeah the way they are you boycotting
the Beverly hotel
because they're gonna yeah Beverly Hills
Hotel because that owned by the Sultan
of Brunei habitat I generally spend a
lot of money at the Beverly I
right you people wake up for me a but
yeah I mean
I think these are all say the same thing
you know if we talk about
a oppression of women and we talk about
oppression a baby estate values what
we're really talking about is that the
%ah kersee
trying to maintain its religious values
which are patriarchy
and kind of core you know power in the
hands of the
rich in the hands of the people who who
can use
me kinda religious codes to control the
decisions that
the that lesser than than the I mean it
age-old story
it's depressing as shit that we're
living in 2014 and we're seeing this but
it doesn't surprise me that saudi arabia
make these decisions what pisses me off
is that they're a strong ally of America
same as Brunei by the way we're now I
have a country with Sharia law
and that's all because family also I bet
that that connecting I wanted to bring
other with I without getting into major
geopolitical discussion
do we have to reevaluate some a bar
alliances and some these places that
such horrific human rights where they're
literally stoning gay people to that
and for the third time now women can't
boat and I mean it's such a fundamental
basic
simply America do we have to reevaluate
who were friends with
even though yet it got all apparently
like yeah I
I was actually going to pose that
question to you guys because it's like a
really touchy subject but
I find it hard to imagine that I'm in a
country that supporting
that type of environment people I feel
so bad I get messages from people all
the time
for Middle East and they're scared to
even write me a message
because if somebody were to see if they
could be executed yeah so for people to
have to live in that
are people who are being killed because
they're gay like I just I just don't
understand why
we would you know use money as and I
have an incentive to support that type
environment
and that's the problem were so
entrenched in this kind of American
exceptionalism in this
political like whatever my country think
I think you that we actually use phrases
like
why do we support fucking support their
but my government does and that's
unfortunate for a lot of people
because it make us look on the world
stage
like we are willing to turn the other
way
a were willing to turn the it turn the
other way about the human rights
violations which we r
which we exactly and that's the real
problem why not
right but as a nation we are in that
basically because of what you said it
that dependence on oil and I think that
if we got to a place where we
where left depended on fossil fuels
and I'm not even about foreign
battlefields fossil fuels in general and
we were really embraced a more green
movement which is helpful for
a million reasons is helpful to the
economy it helpful to the environment I
mean there's
only positive side effect that making
these decisions
we this won't even this will be a
conversation
Obama would immediately be like fuck you
guys want to give you eight anymore non
tell you
you know lift this ban or not until you
stop you know
killing people for their belief even
Obama is not about politics I can't
believe who
I just a little bit like by Alaska's
were talking about atheism
what what do you guys personally say to
the people that say there are no
atheists in foxholes
to the people that they are on on your
deathbed you are going to retract
everything you believe and much more
shit
take a horrible that horrible I know
that Christopher Hitchens spoke a lot
about that whenever he was dying
yet he definitely didn't take back
anything that he said I think that
really it and salt to your intelligence
saying
you obviously can't hold your beliefs
true because if you were in a situation
you throw it so you're
almost in a phase until you need God or
religion or something and that's just
insulting to your character and your
intelligence yeah
it also putting such a strange onus on
the Absa we think like their
can believe everything they believe they
retired to the letter to you
it's just one more way for them if they
were right and you're wrong because one
day you're gonna agree with me
it through this if we were raised in a
nation
where religion was never taught where
there was no cultural bias toward
religion
and then we went to war for our country
and then we found ourselves in a box all
we wouldn't makeup but not that I've got
like
were thirtieth by default religion is
indoctrinated
into us so of course some people go back
to their
earlier mentalities because they were
raised that way but I don't know any
ABS who in the late stages of life who
were never exposed to religion who are
all the sudden like
I'm going to invent some sort of
religion as a as a means the feeling
safe and and comfortable gonna bring
that up I met a lot of people
who are raising their kids about
religion and
I've had a conversation with the kid
know what I just don't understand how
people think these crazy things you know
I don't believe in Santa Claus anymore
and I think it's really important that
people could just step back and imagine
that they never had that a doctor nation
imagine that they never
were brought up with religion an entire
self the religion story again whether
your Muslim or Christian or whatever you
are it would sound ridiculous
so I wanna ask those people who ask me
what I would do my deathbed wall
why on your deathbed argument start
praying to Allah yeah
you know you could be wrong might as
well cover all the bases yeah
that you know a common thing that they
that they say kinda been a bf their
goals which is that
were all ABS I just go one God Mar a nap
I
very ago I hope we gave you a smart
heavy show is a promise up top I want to
thank jacqueline Glen
caravan Maria their twitters a right now
below don't forget to subscribe
comment all backed up that we
indoctrinate you to do
on the YouTube because that is truly the
supreme power
okay with the next week